good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it what are you
reading well I just read an amazing book
by a first novelist named Hank green I
don't want to say anything more until
it's available for pre-order but Wow
it's like properly brilliant and now I'm
reading an introduction to global health
delivery which is quite different from
Hanks book but also excellent what's
your favorite song at the moment so my
kids have discovered that their uncle
Hank is a musician whose songs you can
listen to on Spotify and they won't stop
listening to him I've probably heard
this is in Hogwarts 10,000 times in the
last two weeks and I have to say it's
pretty darn good is this becoming a hank
green appreciation vlog no more Hank for
the rest of the video thoughts on breaks
it and pears now that is a question
Tuesday question so sometimes I'll be at
the grocery store and I'll think you
know what future me would like to eat
pears a ton of pears and so I'll buy a
bunch of pears and then later when I am
future me I'll open up the refrigerator
and think oh I really wish I hadn't
gotten these pears I wish I could just
return them and get my money back
because I completely miss a pre hendon
my appetite for pears but you can't
return pears
speaking of which pears or apples I
don't know if we're still talking about
brexit but regardless apples in Turtles
all the way down how can Daisy say that
Attack of the Clones is the most
underrated Star Wars movie that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard I'm
gonna try not to respond to hostility
with hostility here but look Daisy's
wrong about a lot of things but she is
right about this Empire Strikes Back
correctly rated as the best Star Wars
movie a new hope also correctly rated as
excellent Return of the Jedi is if
anything slightly overrated rogue one in
the force awakens are both rated
correctly The Phantom Menace is
correctly rated as the worst Revenge of
the Sith widely and appropriately
believed to be the best of the prequels
leaving Attack of the Clones as the only
and ergo most underrated Star Wars movie
hey Jon you working on anything new yeah
I've got a new series over at hankgames
called John Green salt your problems in
which i play fifa while solving people's
problems so far I've solved the problem
of somebody who couldn't reach the spot
on their back that itched and someone
else whose taste was too expensive for
their budget but over the course of many
episodes I'm hoping you know to solve
all of the problems hey which charities
won the project for awesome money these
25 charities will all be getting grants
from this year's project for awesome
congratulations to them and thank you
again to everyone who donated how do you
deal with stress poor
favorite Winona Ryder movie heathers are
you having a midlife crisis yet maybe a
little bit how important is nature to
you I think the thing to remember is
that we are nature just as much as like
birds and trees are so very important
why isn't there any turtles all the way
down Murch
there is at dftba.com you can find
amazing posters and also a wonderful
pencil set with quotes from the book
favorite Marvel character probably the
Hulk favorite DC character right now
probably Paul man afford I cannot look
away from the Paul Manafort storyline
are you upset about this now I'm just
glad my books can be useful when did you
get a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
I did into that star belongs to the John
Green who won five Oscars not me who
once won an MTV Movie Award what is the
most likely way for humans to go extinct
this is a question I spend a fair amount
of time thinking about
I think disease is still most likely
followed by some kind of AI or post
human species rendering us obsolete
followed by an extinction level war
basically I still think it's most likely
that microorganisms will be our undoing
but I think there is a growing
possibility that we will be our own
undoing how do you stop worrying about
not living your life to the fullest well
I don't know how to stop worrying but I
do think the idea of living your life to
the fullest is a little flawed like why
is jumping out of an airplane inherently
better than reading a book or why is
living a life that looks good on
Instagram inherently more meaningful
than a life lived quietly I just don't
buy it like Eudora Welty wrote a
sheltered life can be a daring life as
well for all serious daring starts from
within so live your life Hank I will see
you on Friday